singt jetzt der steueranteil auf den
spritpreis ja oder nein das habe ich
jetzt gerade noch nicht verstanden habe
ich auch noch nicht verstanden der
finanzminister hat er geschafft heute
zwei positionen heute schon zu haben
heute morgen in einem interview hatte er
gesagt die preise werden nicht gesenkt
das wird nichts gemacht so wie letzte
woche bei ihnen auch ein nein heute
wahrscheinlich hat die fdp intern viel
miteinander diskutiert gab es an diesem
tweet der was ankündigt man muss sich ja
erinnern das weiß auch christian dürr
wenn eine partei in den letzten jahren
auch im bundestagswahlkampf immer wieder
und ich würde sogar sagen an manchen
stellen zu recht die entlastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger angemahnt hat
dann war es die fdp und kaum stellt sie
den finanzminister ist jeder euro mehr
für den staat ein guter euro das passt
nicht und deswegen gerade bei den
spritpreisen bei den energiepreisen
braucht es jetzt konkrete entlastungen
da geht's auch nicht wie herr stegner
gerade gesagt hat müssen wir mal schauen
was sich noch entwickelt hat heute vor
allem in köln ich habe vorhin in köln
getankt 2 eur 33 hat da der liter
gekostet wenn du 50 liter tanks bist du
schon fast bei 120 euro und das trifft
viele bei mir im münsterland in
deutschland insgesamt pendler familien
jeder der irgendwie mal tanken muss
überlegt sich mittlerweile ob er das tun
kann und diese bürgerinnen und bürger
brauchen entlastung jetzt in dem der
spritpreis mindestens mal noch einmal
ganz klar ein endlager stand doch
eigentlich nur eins sagen da vor der tür
wird gleich sagen haushaltsmittel
braucht es dafür sorry ich sage noch
einmal ein prozent inflation zehn
milliarden euro steuermehreinnahmen und
gerade auch jetzt bei den gestiegenen
energiepreisen bei der mehrwertsteuer
automatisch verdient der staat mit
ruhiger hand geld zurückzugeben dass der
staat ungerechtfertigterweise mehr hat
und von herrn stegner erwarte ich das
gar nicht von der fdp erwarte ich dass
jetzt die bürgerinnen und bürger
entlastet da hängt ja also herr spahn
ist gleich gekommen ist eine opposition
ist es schlau geworden so wie
hans in zu im saarland ja dann
vorstellen ja populistische ansagen der
punkt ist er natürlich darauf
hingewiesen wir haben eine entlassung
pakets beschlossen das wirkt noch gar
nicht das wird kommen da wird entlastung
bei der pendlerpauschale zum beispiel
geben das wird aber nicht ausgleichen
wir haben die wirtschaftsinstitute schon
gesagt werden freibeträge erhöht und ich
habe herrn lindner nicht so verstanden
dass sie das der anteil wird gesenkt hat
gesagt er werde über andere
entlastungsmaßnahmen zu reden haben
insbesondere bei denen die viel fahren
müssen bei denen die geringe und normale
einkommen haben da gibt es verschiedene
bereiche noch die
pauschale die hilfen erhöhen die wir
schon geschlossen haben dass da kann
über noch was drauf gelegt werden aber
ein schuss sozusagen mal soeben
angekündigt von jemand der gerade in die
opposition gewechselt ist das ist billig
und so werden wir das auch nicht machen
so wie wenn das solide miteinander
diskutieren und dann wird am ende ein
maßnahmenpaket geben für das eine
mehrheit sie nennen das was herr sparen
sagt billig das was sie gerade machen
ist ziemlich teuer wir können uns noch
mal auf denen auf die säule uns noch
einmal vergewissern wie hoch ist aktuell
liege der steueranteil auf den sprit
gucken wir uns nochmal genau
wie das aktuell aussieht wir haben
einmal als richtwert ein literpreis von
2 eur 9 genommen und da sehen wir dass
da immer noch mehr steuer drin steckt in
diesem lied als tatsächlich rohölpreis
also alles was gelb und rot ist gehört
sozusagen den finanzminister erst mal
und alles was graues ist der ölpreis den
können sie derzeit kaum beeinflussen und
von dem riesigen batzen gibt es im
moment nichts herz gegeben hätte
nein so ist es ja nicht und mit verlaub
das was wir einsparen gerade gemacht hat
das war leider auch populismus das waren
krokodilstränen also das ergebnis was
sie gerade an die wand geworfen haben
ist ja 16 jahre unionsgeführte
bundesregierung aber das war doch gehört
der schulter das stimmt und das stimmt
da hat herr spahn eine riesen
verantwortung mitzutragen wenn ich mein
vermögen hat festhalten dass für den
krieg putin angekündigt ist und für den
überfall auf
das war die folge gerade auch mit
verantwortlich ist und vielleicht können
wir ja auch festhalten das könnte jetzt
noch alles so machen das macht er ja in
der ampelkoalition jetzt seit drei
monaten in jeder debatte 16 jahre das
könnte er vielleicht noch drei monate
länger machen aber eins müsste halt
jetzt mal schon akzeptieren hier regiert
jetzt es regiert die fdp und deswegen
konkret löst sie reden gerade an den
zuschauern vorbei herr dürr sparen sie
reden an den zuschauern vorbei dass er
einfach für die zeit nach dieser sendet
aufheben einfach sagen er
wurde ersparen einfach was falsches
gerade in der öffentlichkeit gesagt hat
er hat gerade behauptet der staat hat
krassem er einmal im sommer so machen
jens spahn ist viel schlauer als dass er
weiß nämlich dass natürlich die
gestiegenen kosten auch gegen
gewinnsteuern gerechnet werden der staat
hat an anderer stelle und das sind keine
krokodile jetzt von meiner seite ich
will es noch einmal feststellen weil
jens spahn behauptet das wären alles
durch mehr einnahmen denkbar das ist
schlicht die unwahrheit gewesen was er
gerade gesagt hat denn wir haben an
anderer stelle finde ich klasse
mindereinnahmen dh wer jetzt sagt dieser
steuer ein teil des staates der muss
quasi abgeschafft werden der muss schon
sagen die bei ihren sparen wo das ganze
heer kommt es ist nicht die wahrheit
dass der staat summa summarum zurzeit
mehr einen er nicht gerade weniger an
wir werden das bei der kommenden
steuerschätzung sehen und noch mal ich
bin sehr dafür sieht das genauso wie der
kollege stegner das ist eine ampel neben
den 16 milliarden die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen werden in den kommenden
wochen dass wir dann eben uns auch diese
energie steuern der alten koalition und
insbesondere der hätten bundesliga noch
wir haben ja hier und da haben wir 45
minuten da los haben wir die
verantwortung dieser einfachen frage wir
nehmen uns noch mal diesen steueranteil
auf sprit vor da gibt es jetzt sie
können das populistisch oder billig
nennen da gibt es eine klare antwort von
jens sparen darauf dass die steuern
sinken müssen tobias hans im saarland
klar der steckt im moment im wahlkampf
aber der macht einen vorschlag der sagt
53 cent davon runter letzte woche hier
der finanzminister christian lindner der
ganz klar sagt von diesen steuern wird
hier immer komisch gesenkt heute in dem
tweet irgendwie schon wieder anders und
ich möchte einfach verstehen wofür
stehen sie jetzt ist das ausgeschlossen
dass sie die steuern auf schritt senken
werden ja oder nein